this is curtin davina reading for jason
finelli pokemon unite
gets a lot of things right the game
feels like a moba such as league of
legends or
dota 2 but is much easier to understand
for those who've never played a moba
before
matches are short snappy affairs with
plenty of action and strategy
learning each of the five classes is fun
and rewarding
each skirmish within a match ups the
ante increasing tension and excitement
until it boils over in the final stretch
it's just a shame that the confusing
in-game economy composed of multiple
currencies
and a loopbox style lottery system can
sometimes get in the way
of the fun
for those unaware pokemon unite is a
multi-player
online battle arena game or moba
two teams of up to five players choose a
pokemon then
enter an arena where they defeat wild
pokemon in the environment
to gather energy and experience
experience levels up a pokemon
increasing its stats and powering up its
moves while energy
is used to score points and win the game
this is where pokemon unite
separates itself from traditional mobas
pokemon must take their stored energy to
an opposing team's goal
and dunk it through the hoop to score
points
equal to how much energy the pokemon
held
dunks aren't the only scoring method
though as special wild pokemon sometimes
appear
that give temporary buffs or extra
points
but they're rare and they're sometimes
one-time occurrences during a match
when time runs out 10 minutes in a
standard match whoever has the most
points
wins this goal scoring approach is
different from established moba games
but it's a fantastic choice most of the
wild pokemon in the arena
aren't difficult to beat so even novice
players will be able to gather
energy easily
[Music]
some goals can only have so many points
scored on them before they break
meaning disabled goals force you to
progress further into the opponent's
side of the arena to find a new one
it's a fun spin on the core objective of
a moba match
taking something like defeating towers
and league of legends in order to
progress
and making it unique also since the
goals don't fight back like league of
legends towers do
new mobile players won't need to worry
about extra
threats when trying to score pokemon
unite does a great job of making each
match
feel exciting you'll feel a quick bond
with teammates who stick to their roles
and support
as needed and you'll feel embarrassed
for that one player doing their own
thing and getting crushed for it
every mid-match skirmish where you and
your teammates are meeting a group of
opponents as tense and exciting and
emerging victorious is thrilling
the 20 pokemon on the pokemon unite
roster fall into one of five
categories attacker all rounder
speedster defender and supporter
these categories describe how each one
should be controlled
leaning into the genre's strategic
elements team balance is also a big
factor in a moba player's success
and unite does a good job of allowing
players to balance their teams how they
wish
small hints on the character select
screen will let the team know
which role has not yet filled while
chosen pokemon are faded out to clearly
show who's still available
as you gain experience the pokemon
special attacks will power up
first changing to a new move and then
adding an enhanced version
while that sounds like a lot the game
does a great job of making everything
clear
in real time pokemon unite serves as a
tremendous entry point into what may be
a new genre for many players
it's easy to pick up and play giving
everyone a chance to learn
what mobas are all about moba veterans
may find the game a little too
simplistic though
lacking the deep gameplay and strategic
elements of league of legends or dota
the speed of the matches coupled with
the approachable mechanics makes
grinding for higher levels
easy without feeling repetitive grinding
has its benefits too
with trainer levels that give you access
to new modes and rewards
and an optional battle pass that gives
even more reward drops
there are ways around grinding as well
if you want to speed things up but
unfortunately
that means you have to deal with
microtransactions
the achilles heel of pokemon unite the
game's easy
streamlined processes and gameplay goes
out the window when the game's economy
enters the discussion there are five
different in-game currencies
four of which are earned by plane there
are eos coins
eos tickets fashion tickets and hollow
ware tickets
the lone premium currency are eos gems
which are only available via real money
and can be used to purchase
some of the things the other free
currencies can buy
like unite licenses to access playable
pokemon
or boosts to battle points to gain
levels faster
having five currencies is an
unnecessarily confusing system
four of them are earned by playing the
game meaning that everything available
can
technically be earned by grinding out
matches but the rates at which some
currencies are earned are unreasonably
low
the paid currency wouldn't be inherently
bad if it were only used for cosmetic
items such as those skins but eos gems
can also be used to purchase unite
licenses
to unlock pokemon and temporary boosts
for eos coins
in battle pass points allowing you to
more quickly unlock items that can be
used
in battle while buying a unite license
for a pokemon just gives a player access
to that pokemon early which isn't a big
deal outside of being able to use a
pokemon in battle sooner it's the items
that are
a key example of why this economy can
feel unbalanced
and the shops are two types of items
held items which give your pokemon
permanent boost
in a match and battle items which are
activated with a button press and can
give a temporary perk like heel damage
or
increased attack power by pumping money
into the game via the premium currency
either to boost coin gain or using the
gems to purchase the items directly
a player can purchase and use these
items faster than someone who's not
buying gems
don't get me wrong pokemon unite is an
enjoyable game
the moba genre fits the pokemon
franchise very well
and as more pokemon are introduced the
meta game will likely to continue to
evolve
and may introduce more fun opportunities
to strategize
dropping into battle with new builds and
trying new things is fun
as is taking a newly earned pokemon into
a battle and seeing what they can do
what's not enjoyable is the game's
economy if microtransactions weren't so
incentivized we'd be looking
at the next major pokemon success story
knowing that they are however player
beware
[Music]
what is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
five four three
two one time's up
[Music]
you win